[موسيقى]
اخبار حرب غزه بايجاز من جنوب لبنان اهلا
بكم عدد الشهداء في غزه يرتفع الى اكثر من
9 و2 بينهم اكثر من
3800 طفل على الاقل وزاره الصحه قالت ان
الاحتلال ارتكب مجزره امام مشفى الشفاء في
وقت اظهر فيه تسجيل المصور اشلاء شهداء
سقطوا في قصف استهدف نازحين على طريق
الرشيد
الساحلي امانه يا رب تحمي شعب امانه يا رب
اطلع حسبي الله ونعم
الوكيل كتائب القسام تعلن قتل اربعه جنود
اسرائيليين شمال غرب بيت لاهيا وتقول انها
اشتبكت مع قوه اسرائيليه راجله غرب ايريز
في حين اعترف الجيش الاسرائيلي بارتفاع
عدد قتلاه الى
25 منذ بدء التوغل البري وقال انه حاصر
مدينه غزه
بالكامل في الضفه الغربيه عشره شهداء على
الاقل نتيجه مواجهات بين مقاومين وقوه
اسرائيليه خاصه في جنين واقتحامات وقصف
اسرائيلي في مدن عده الامم المتحده وصفت
الوضع في الضفه بالمقل وبانه يستدعي تحركا
عاجلا وقالت ان عنف المستوطنين تصاعد بشكل
كبير وبلغ مستويات
قياسيه الامين العام لحزب الله اللبناني
يقول ان معركه طوفان الاقصى فلسطينيه 100%
ولكنها اصبحت امتد في اكثر من جبهه واكثر
من ساحه مشددا على ان حزبه انخرط فيها من
البدايه ومستمر في خوضها الى
اللقاء